okay hello everyone
welcome to our third live stream of the
day
um
well from language design our language
completeness and consistency series
we are looking at a variety of topics
today what on earth is a
graph theme okay this is going to be
interesting yeah so so
uh i think the first two topics will
definitely require some explanation
so iniko in unic we're used to thinking
of sort of there being a one-to-one
correspondence between code points and
characters which are technically called
graphemes
but there really
isn't um
and
so our our string functions have a long
and proud tradition of trading strings
is just a sequence of code points and i
have here
the uh
you know example of a linear syntax
string and you string reverse it and you
get
junk
um
and so the suggestion is that you know
and i don't think we can change the
string functions at least by default
because there's just too many
assumptions everywhere that
you know
you can't just sort of use it as a way
to represent the string of bytes
um
so we're trying to solve the problem
let's say i have an x sub 1 and a string
or a red x in a string
right now if i s what time that is not
the problem we're trying to solve
if i say characters of a string that has
that red x in the middle of it what will
happen
you'll get you'll get a bunch of
interesting characters it will not be
one character right
okay is that the problem we're trying to
solve is that no we're trying to solve a
more sub more fundamental problem
would that be a problem we want to solve
possibly but but i think that i think
that is a less important problem to
solve
what happens here if i how do i get that
to jump to reality well you you can't
because
uh pictures
yeah okay just just do this delete the
string
delete the whole thing yeah uh now empty
string x just type it in empty string x
and then x with another
uh and and and then do it by hand
yeah okay
uh text color
red
or whatever
yeah
and then evaluate it spluff
insanity
and so this is speaking you know this is
basically
uh
you know are trying to embed box
structures in streams
but but the only way we can do it is
by you know using three things so
i know so what we might think in a
different world that this would turn
into two characters an x
charact an x
single character string and a red x
pseudo single character string yeah
right but we we have bigger fish to fry
so
okay on the big special emoji
right so i'm not not just emoji but
emoji are providing good examples okay
right and so for example if you look at
the first example i'm string joining two
two one character strings
now if you were to cursor through that
output you would see that there is now
only one character there
effectively
and and notice this is not an emoji so
it's not an emoji only problem
right just for my education what is that
a hebrew character or what is it yes
that is the shin and then that's
valmark
okay
so it's a diacritical basically yes and
what languages i mean you know dead keys
are a a thing
right and this even affects european
languages i actually have an example of
that later in this section
okay um
so
um
right now if you reverse the code points
you know it may not be sort of
the same
right it may not have any sort of
validity so that sort of one emoji
you
reverse it and you end up something that
looks like three things although it's
really two things why is that why is
characters giving isn't that just a
24-bit
i mean no no
four code points
i had no idea so emoji are often
composites yes sometimes sometimes yes
sometimes no i do
right
my gosh my whole emoji world is
shattered
is that is that a 205 character some
kind of um that is the zero width joiner
which is why that output which looks
like three things is actually two
two graphemes if you cursor through that
one of them will take you through the
emoji and the other
left arrow will take you through
the color and the hat in in one step
because they've been joined by a single
string character
yeah so it's even weirder than you think
because you think you're looking at
three characters but you're only looking
at two there cursor through it to see it
happen
here in this one yes yes
okay
yeah
right and then so getting almost to the
european language the same string might
be represented in multiple ways with a
different number of code points so here
i have the letter sheen with its
associated dot
i normalize it and it still looks like
the same character but now it's
two characters the bass letter sheen and
the shin dot
and here's the other way i've
constructed an a-tilde from two
code points but if it there of course
there's also the a tilde character which
is a single code point
right so this is a
this is a dead key diacritical mark is
that right in other words that's a
because not every
or does every
is there a way of getting that
diacritical mark
without having it go on top of something
no it's always going to go it's always
going to be a a
go back one
it doesn't go back one character and
wrap itself on top or what does it do
rob are you able to opine on that point
i mean the double quote is a is a
special case because we need to be able
to terminate strings
um but if you wanna if you in the
interactive examples there's a palette
that allows you to create some of these
crazy things
and uh
evaluate yeah
so you see that palette and so
you know when when you see those arrows
there one is the
is all four together and then the one
the thing on the right is you know how
you type it in one at a time to compose
the letter
okay the hungarian flag
what is this that is a flag h so if you
type in the country code using the flag
alphabet
it will turn into a flag that's freaking
crazy right so so in fact do gb
that's an interesting thing i learned
yesterday
[Music]
that i did not know that even though
the uk uses the uk
domain name the official country code
according to the iso standard is gb
which is complete nuts but
great britain it's that's like
on you know when you take it
to the car right but
yes but last time i checked it's the
united kingdom of great britain and
northern ireland
uh well yes when i was a kid i'd never
heard the term uk it was always gb ah
interesting so it's a more recent
phenomenon the uk thing being the the
main
story okay
um
i had no idea that there was a flag
alphabet
so so if i type like um
uh
you know what is it like m
oh will i get like the moldovan flag
wow
that's so funky
so this is like tlds
now yeah it's technically the iso
two-letter
country abbreviation uh which is often
the same as the
top-level domain but as you can see
in the case of
so why did that that was that that
became a a single character when i did a
single backspace i did a single cursor
the ww there is now even though i typed
them as two so so basically one of the
messages here just because you type it
as two characters doesn't mean it is two
characters correct
uh and and let me let me show you
something else uh that will also blow
your mind uh
go ahead and type in us for the u.s flag
okay
now arrow now arrow to the left
and now put in an h
the ordinary letter h or an h no no no
the flag age
i'm going to cut the hungarian flag
aren't i yes you are
[Laughter]
that's absolutely freaking crazy
oh my gosh
wow
so in other words these things haven't
really composed themselves they're
sitting there by the way what is this is
this a string if i put
well
it's presumably a symbol with a symbol
name if you put it in in double quotes
then it'll be a string oh yeah and yeah
anything we don't know about is a letter
like character which means it can be
used in a symbol
okay so we can do that for example
okay
okay
maybe that's the solution to us running
out of keyboard things we start putting
emoji in which we don't yet have any
parsing for emoji do we
um
so so all
all the emoji characters are treated as
letter-like for the time being it may
make sense to add some things that that
do something different um
but i'm not sure if you're thinking of a
new category or just re-categorizing
some of the existing things um i think
every category i mean i'm asking the
question if there was an emoji like like
you know let's imagine that we wanted to
have i mean this gets kind of silly but
amusing you know if we want to have some
burrowing animal that represents you
know some kind of map function
sure absolutely in principle
that's something that we could do it's
not something that users could do
because users aren't able to to
re-categorize characters like that but
uh but it is something we could do yes
boy that would be that would be amusing
to have our language be to be able to
write instead of slash at to be able to
write some kind of burrowing character
there
burrowing animal
there as you can see you could use the
flags as the corresponding entities
yes we could
that would be cute
that'd be really cute
um what would be the flag entity or or
the country entity
now now that having been said uh
although the rules for clustering
graphemes are the same across all
platforms
but uh
things that draw
you know how they draw that's not the
same across platforms and
so for example uh
right now windows i'm not sure about
windows 11 but definitely windows 10 uh
out of the box does not draw flag emojis
any flag emojis at all no boy
okay but i mean but that's like saying
there's a font missing right and on
linux you don't get the color you get an
as sort of an outline of different okay
question
is is it like can you load the emoji in
like you can load in a font
uh yes
i i i haven't verified that i can do it
with with flag emoji specifically but in
general the answer is yes okay by the
way sandra livestream makes the obvious
point that country data should get a
flag emoji property
yes
yeah that makes sense
okay all right
so where are we going with all of this
right so the question is what happens if
you want to
you know right you have a string of
flags and you want to reverse the order
of the flags right so you don't want to
do it
code point by code point because that
would not just be reversing the order of
the flags that would be changing the
flags
sure so we want functions that might
why does string reverse i mean
the question is
what is characters of this
right it's going to be
two and the number of flags you see uh i
mean you need quotes yeah yeah you need
to make it a string
and
you know changing the default behavior
is very problematic uh
the uh and it's bound to cause all kinds
of breakage i mean you assume
that an individual element returned by
characters is something that when you do
two character code on it it's going to
return one value uh for example
that seems like a safe assumption um
before we start implementing graphemes
and you know but in the world of
graphenes it's not safe at all
okay
what is your proposal to have a whole
new family of functions called grapheme
whatever instead of character whatever
that is that is one possibility i mean i
suppose the other possibility is some
sort of option to
[Music]
uh
functions you know to all the string and
character functions um
extended syntax or
right i mean but but for many people
it's the do it wrong or do it right type
question i mean in other words if i just
take this
and i say string reverse of that people
are going to expect
i mean people are not going to expect
that
right
so i mean
if if we were considering the
possibility
of sort of literal code points arrow
true or false
whatever we want to call it
to do this
and the default behavior being do the
obvious thing
that seems like the right thing to me
and your but your claim is that will
break code
right uh
high money well maybe maybe not a huge
amount of currency just because we
uh because nobody could have used this
stuff i mean none of this would have
worked before
oh it's you you're worried about the
corner case if somebody says
i've got you know if i say okay so the
question here is
what is string length of this
yes
okay and that also has affect the red x
story wherever that was correct
yeah
what's the string length of that
and right now oops
let's do this here
and right now that's kind of about to be
bonkers that
that's just bonkers
yeah
well it's it is the length you would get
if you did you know two string input
form on that
and and it should be pointed out that
there are people who use string
functions to operate on linear form and
it's terrible and horrible and painful
and causes you know bald patches from
where you tore your hair out but people
have done it
and that code
kind of works now
right
well okay so
i mean we could initially
introduce an option
that is not on by default
that does the right thing so to speak
because as you say it may have weird
corner cases
of what do you really want it to do do
you want it to treat
okay so the basic question is what
define for me a grapheme is a grapheme
the individual sub pieces like the the u
and the s and the us flag where is the
graphene the flag itself the grapheme is
the flag itself the grapheme is you know
a sequence of code points that are in
some sense indivisible of course until
you
divide them but
so i mean it would not be unreasonable
to have something called graphemes along
with something called characters
yeah
what what makes this a bit more
confusing
is that uh in the parlance out in the
world
uh of of
unicode uh
that
they
you know so they have graphemes and they
have code points and then when they say
characters they tend to mean graphemes
they don't tend to mean code points
right
yes although they also talk about code
points representing abstract characters
so
i think it's a bit muddled one way or
the
both ways okay
but so okay so look we've got and and
let me just sort of raise the question
so suppose
uh you did
write the example where i showed that
sort of the same
token can be
uh represented in two different ways
right as one code point or two code
points if you do string match queue of
those two things should that be
true or false
i'm sorry say that okay okay with so
this is well
if it's represented two different ways i
mean it's like algebraic expressions all
bets are off
yeah
now i mean if you look at uh what the
unicode consortium has to say about this
you know they they make this claim
with the understanding that it's a lot
of work on the people that are
implementing these things but they make
this claim that you know those
different forms of strings of characters
should be considered equivalent
and they've proved that it's decidable
there's no series of of things where
that there is a canonical form is there
a okay so let's imagine
well there are multiple canonical forms
depending on
i think they're what five or six if
someone remembers uh
uh
which you know basically
you know
end up deciding on certain things you
know
basically end up prioritizing certain
you know decisions you know i mean you
can have a canonical form where where
everything is expanded out to you know
combining characters you can have a
canonical form where you know all the
combining characters that have an
equivalent single code point uh you know
are replaced with that single code point
and there are others right
right and and and for example
and i i just don't know what the
standard is at this point you know what
the standard has to say about this but
right in hebrew you can you might need
multiple diacritics diacritics to
uh you know right because you might need
an accent mark and and the vowel and if
you're doing
biblical hebrew you might also need one
or two cantillation marks
and so then does the order does the
canonicalization say what order those go
into i i just don't know but i assume it
does i mean i know that i think i've
been told that khmer is the language in
the world which has the most collection
of diacritical marks
um
and you know like five or six or
something per character in some cases
um
yeah i mean there has to be look it's
like the big red dog the red big dog
there's got to be some canonical order
um
but your point is do you use
you know a diacritical mark umlaut or
whatever or do you use the a or not
character
exactly either of those could be the
canonical form
right so if you look at the character
normalize page which is the one function
we have that sort of you know even
vaguely aware of these issues
then i think it gives us
two of those
and it's it's experimental so we can
certainly change the name or
change the implementation um yeah i
remember these issues of um yeah and
these four forms here are the same four
forms if you go to
unicode you know the unicode uh websites
page about normalization you'll see
those same four forms
but now
we would not normally
these should all be displayed the same
if we were doing everything right right
we wouldn't actually see this dz thing
separated would we
uh
once again it may depend on
platform-dependent rendering issues
okay but fundamentally those should be
this is like
in in a per in a perfect world the
answer would be yes
but the world may not be perfect for
reasons outside of our control okay but
so in principle such a normalization
could exist for graphics you know we
have a a red circle a blue circle and
doesn't matter what order those are in
doesn't matter they can be specified in
multiple ways we could have a canonical
form for our random graphics too we
don't happen to have that
right well except of course the order
does matter when they overlapped
yeah yeah
but okay so the question sorry i was
going to ask given given that in a
perfect world the inputs and outputs
there would look the same
as wondering if the examples shouldn't
include something like two character
code of both of them or some things or
yeah
um
yeah well right yeah well and and
actually i mean if you look at the uh
uh
here
i'm gonna throw a url in the chat uh if
you look at the
unicode page for this uh just a little
down from the top they have some nice
visualizations
of what these uh
what these normalization forms look like
yeah i think we looked at this before
okay
well anyway but but yeah okay so oh
interesting so they they don't
necessarily look identical
or do they
right because i see one i one i see is a
ligature and the other is non-ligatured
um
okay anyway let's come back to what our
assume is here and what we're trying to
achieve
so
the main
okay
i think string equality putting look
we've got ignore case
which is a way of doing certain
operations
with i mean you know ignore
normalization or something ignore
character normalization or some such
other thing should be the one that tries
to do the transmissions just like ignore
case tries to fold the cases
that seems fairly uncontroversial
then i think we need an option
that
i don't know whether it's called
character normalization error to a false
or what it's called
that
um i'm not sure what what the that that
tries to
that tries to decide whether we should
take
whether the lumberjack
it could be something like preserve
joined forms or something like that
that's as obscure as i don't think i
mean but unless you know it's a
character thing if you don't see that
whatever the name yeah i suppose that's
true
right so i mean
what that will do
is to treat like if you do a string
reverse it will treat
the composite object
as a single
right as an m
and same would happen with a red x
but we treat that as a as a single
character
now i would like to ask if we have
square root of x is that a single
character or not
right and that's why i i want to set
aside the
the linear syntax form
um
okay but i think there's a there's a
separate issue there but i think it's
not unreasonable to just say
um
uh
you know
there's a there's a an option setting
for which every blob of linear syntax is
a single character
even if it's square root of one plus x
squared
it's a blob treat it as a single
character don't try and reverse its
elements for example
i think that's a reasonable every
backslash x clam becomes a single blob
right
um
yeah oh and and ultimately you don't
have much choice on that i mean you know
your backslash s claim could be a
graphic yeah sure but it's it's um so i
think that's a useful thing to treat as
a single character
and to treat all of these composite
specifications of characters as single
characters
um
there's a question on livestream about
what about sorting
that is a total mess what is your thing
yeah i have no idea which country comes
first
um
i mean there are
there are rules which i'm not
remembering i wasn't prepared to talk
about that um
bob do you happen to know
are you with us i mean sorting in
general is
should be done on some sort of
normalized form um
okay
and the exact normalized form might
depend on the content
excuse me on the context but if you are
you know looking at
um a list of file names in the finder
that's how it works it normalizes the
file names using a certain set of
normalizations and then it does the
sorting based on the normalized form
you need to turn them into strings
stephen
right you need
oh that was my problem
by the way why are they why are they up
a bit from the baseline is that just the
way they are that's just the way the
glyph draws
you know what insanity what i'm going to
do here
oh my gosh oh i see i have to start you
need to string joints and join it yeah
and don't forget uh i know
if we had percent modernization i would
be prompted oh look at that
now my question is look at all those
flags now how do i tell next question
how do i tell which one's combined
well
in in some sense all of them did
i understand that
but that's clearly a thing but but
you're asking a question about rendering
um yeah i'd like to know which of these
would render as a single which of these
were i to do ignore
you know because
yeah some of these are the ones that
didn't make a combining character i
don't think i want those no look if i
have two disembodied things that didn't
combine like nm for example here
and and let's say i don't think that i
want that
to be treated as a single character
under any circumstances
just because there might be some rule
that says oh if you happen to have this
diacritic and that thing and that thing
that thing they combine if they didn't
actually combine i don't think i want
them treated as a single character
whether they combine can depend on your
os version for example right
well
it depends on the font it depends on the
year
um
it depends where you are
yeah i mean there may very well be i
wouldn't be surprised if there are some
countries
where the fonts that they have uh maybe
include or exclude uh
you know flags that are
disagreed upon perhaps
yeah okay
um
okay but but so but we need some way to
tell like from this i want to be able to
do a select and i want to pick out flags
well and so it but to be clear
what you're asking is a rendering
question which is going to differ
uh you know it's it's not you're not
going to get the same thing
the same version of the product on
different how do i get the bounding box
for the restaurants i think it's just a
bounding box oh bounty box sorry
why is this so damn slow
because it's doing 200
or
more months 26 squared five you know
676. still it is slower than i would
expect for sure um
yeah this this seems
seems like a bug to me
okay well anyway let's let's just um
let's say
okay
so we've got
you know the 17 guys here
no i don't even understand why are there
three numbers the probably best baseline
oh okay
a little confusing but anyway um
okay there's got to be a way to find out
whether they combined more more
efficiently than my rasterizing
so just giving you an idea how this is
currently implemented we hand off the
text to the operating system the
operating system draws it we never get
any information about what actually drew
and what actually draws
as has been stated varies by operating
system and version of operating system
and font installation and so on yeah
exactly yeah
so we don't currently have access to
that information and i'm not sure that
there is a way to get access to it um
from really there's no os call that
gives you that
so
um
so i see you might know something right
assuming this is defined in the standard
then i see you should
know which two letter codes but i i have
no idea if it does and certainly how to
look it up
even if it does have that information
yeah yeah okay so so there are two
different questions here i mean one is
what's in the unicode standard and
that's the sort of thing where yes we
could just you know
you know we we keep updating you know
icu and and query the calls you know
query information from that and it will
give the best information for whatever
version of ic we bundled with that
version of the product um of course you
know if you're using a two-year-old
version it's gonna be out of dates um
so the other possibility is uh that you
know you know the front end queries the
operating system um and this uh you know
i i'll have to
i'm not 100 sure what's possible i'm
pretty sure
that uh i mean on windows we've had this
uh ability to query whether
a single code point has a glyph attached
to it uh and that's a windows specific
thing that i i just happen to know about
um
i'd be perfectly happy to just use the
underlying
library and if the thing renders great
if it doesn't render because you lost a
font or because you know you're in a
country where they outlaw that flag or
something it's just like that that's
i think if you really want to know what
rendered you got to use rasterize
that's my point of view yeah
and you know that will be a corner case
because the the library will give you
most things
so in this particular example i'm
assuming the library will tell you which
of these turned into flags is that true
if that's not true then i'm not so
interested in the library
the library should definitely
i'm assuming that
libicu has that information because it
has lots of this kinds of
of information but i've not confirmed
okay that it does yeah it's a it's a
right it's now officially part of the
ice of the unicode consortium and it
contains all the character data so in
principle
if it's in the standard it should be
accessible from icu but exactly how to
do it and exactly what's in it we don't
know i love the chemistry of flags you
know i could take these two flags i
could concatenate them and then i could
reverse them and i'd get a different you
know i'd get different flags
that's really weird
okay all right so look seems to me what
we need to do
um
i just add a couple of options and
i think we need this function that says
did it turn into a meaningful grapheme
according to our
criteria
character normalizes q or something
right that's not the right name but
that's the concept
i think that's going to be useful
if for nothing else than entertaining
kinds of things like this
but yeah i think adding some options
i mean
if we say
let's see from character code yo wait a
minute yeah right so the options are
going to determine whether the string
functions
go
blob by blob or underlying character by
underlying character
correct
and by the way it's worth understanding
there's another layer which is the byte
layer
where you know a unicode character right
if i go down to the byte layer how do i
how do i do that if i if i take if i
take an alpha for example uh well well
it depends what encoding you're using
right yeah no i know but yeah you'd
you'd want to use you know like two
character code
with uh tf8
yeah utf-8 well i want to i want to what
is the byte array of this
right so that would be string to bite
array now you want string to bite array
which will give you
okay and so that in principle has a
character okay fine that's three bytes
and if i say normal
utf-8 by default
yeah
okay
okay
all right fine so i mean that that's um
uh
so that's another layer of you know what
we are doing by default okay let's just
clarify what we're doing
by default
we are bucketing bytes together at the
level of four byte unicode
is that true
up to the level or is it only up to the
level of two byte unicode we're
automatically bucketing bytes
in a way that they never get broken
apart so so there's a level of
abstraction that you don't have to think
about here because because we do all the
thinking for you which is that
um so
and the distinction here between uh what
they refer to in unicode as code points
versus code units
so a code point is you know u plus xxx
however many x's you know you know
that's a that's a code point you know
you're
uh
but n45 for alpha
yeah
uh but a code unit
is dependent upon are using utf-8 or
utf-16 or utf-32
if you're using utf-32
code unit and code points are the same
thing
but utf-16
is you know because it's 16-bit so uh so
code units
uh you know
end up uh being uh uh
there's times having to use surrogate
pairs
yeah uh to write which we'll talk some
more about in a few minutes yeah to
represent some characters and then utf-8
well you've already seen
yeah you could you need between one and
four
okay but i just i'm just trying to
understand
in what we've done previously an alpha
as a two byte character but we are
always those two bytes are always glued
together
whereas the us flag
is two
you know underlying intermediate
characters not pure byte representations
which are not so firmly glued together
oh the u.s flag yes
right so there are two code points
which you know if you did from
or two character code on one of those
flags yes you would see two numbers
each of which represent a code point and
then
each of those could be some number of
bytes depending on the particular
uh you know unicode representation you
used
the the you know the particular
character encoding whether it's utf-816
utf-8
which apparently exists
which apparently uh exists for if you
need unicode on an ibm mainframe
okay
all right okay i think we've got some
some sense here i think we we know sort
of the general direction to head in i i
don't know about string patterns that
could be fairly horrifying like could
you could you match on the first
you know
whatever you're calling it code point of
a of the us flag
the way things are today absolutely yes
i know
so i think you have a i think you're
bank switching here you're either
dealing with you know in a string
expression
you're either saying treat these as
uh blobs or you're saying treat them
as the level of character that we are
currently dealing with as characters
which means for example in string
expression i think it'd be very nice to
be able to match on
a um
you know on a graphic that is a inline
cell or you know what
what are those called wait a minute what
what's what's the slash x-clam called
oh uh linear form
okay right
yeah
okay so then you know so we're saying
either you can match the explicit linear
form as a blob
or you can match
the um
individual characters
now and then we've also got an ignore
character normalization
which will make it be like ignore case
will make it
kind of
you know normalize everything before the
match
ethan is commenting that you can style
an x character but you cannot style
emojis is that a true statement you can
well certainly yes depends on the emoji
and
the the the style
construct
is there
but
uh
but once again it comes down to
rendering
uh
you know there is no standardized way
for example to italicize an emoji um
okay so if i say this
and certainly changing the font color of
an emoji doesn't even make sense
yeah
it might actually work if you did it
without the
at just one of the regional indicator um
code points
okay so if i if i said something like
style
oops it might not but it might
if i said h there
funky
yeah but so also what if you've done the
flag but background goes to red
okay uh that that would work that would
work
yeah so the uh
i mean you know font rendering is doing
two very different things you know for
color what what's what is called color
fonts uh but really color fonts means
you know images of some sort you know
they might be uh they're typically
bitmaps although they might be svgs
but uh
the you know the way the color fonts are
rendered is very very different from the
way that
monochrome
fonts or yellow the traditional fonts
are rendered and you lose a lot of
functionality
by displaying a glyph that's in a color
font
okay that's just the way it is
yeah fine uh but but you will get some
things i mean like you know for example
font size
you know you can style something to
change his font size that would
absolutely work
oh yeah so it does
why does it have all this border well i
can't even get the border i see
and and the baselines of these things
are defined how
uh font presumably yeah yeah
once again that's coming from the
operating system rendering
i believe that apple's emojis are
designed to all have the same metrics
which is why
uh you have the space uh
extra space that doesn't seem like it
needs to be there for a flag there are
glyphs that
would use
different different spacing
but so so this down here
right this this cell is taller than it i
mean if i say framed
oh my god what just happened there
what the heck happened why is that d in
a different color
[Music]
either you inserted an invisible
character or it's some sort of glitch
can you toggle show expression real
quick
uh oh oh
it's the style box the
oh
yeah yeah
i think it'll work
actually i'm not
sure
oh my god did you see that it just it
waited out yeah well uh
so
this is uh
well this is why the work is in the
prototype branch and not in the
regular nightly build yet so
yeah clearly we we just encountered some
so framed might show something weird
there
yeah
okay
all right let me just look for one
second at these
string join i hate to even imagine what
that will do
but i think that's why
i think i think string join is fine
right the string join is fine right it
might if we have if we have a string
partition which i don't remember if we
do we do you know that then that that
might actually care but string join
right if okay but remember it's either
blobs or not blobs it's either blobs of
characters it knows what to do in each
case if it's a string partition with
blobs it will count the blobs if it's
with characters it counts the characters
right
and it's all good
okay this looks reasonable okay
naked surrogates that sounds like
okay so this is another sort of
horrifying story sounds like some
dystopian
something or other okay
yes so
uh it's more it's supposed to be more
reminiscent of naked singularities
um
so right so unicode one point x is 16
bit
um
and so all values between 0 and 2 to the
16 minus 1 were valid code points
um and early adopters like us and
windows and t allowed strings with all
of those code points
later editions of unicode are 32
quote-unquote 32-bit
and therefore certain
code points
below
2-16 were set aside as no longer being
valid code points to be used as the
so-called surrogate pairs
that you know if you use the utf-16
encoding you take one of one from the
low half and one from the high half and
you stick them together and that's how
you encode things
in the upper ranges of unicode
and sort of a byte sequence is still
formed if it encodes one of those values
as a code points
now isn't the sum of the utf-8 story
that it has it's using something as a
if i'm not how does the tf8 work
utf-8 uh
well it's not quite the same thing but i
mean they're
it is certainly the case that you know
not every
string of
of values is a valid utf-8 string right
uh and so similarly not every string of
16-bit values is a valid utf-16 string
there are uh you know because it's only
valid if
those you know that string of values
renders a series of code points and
if you know if you get you know
uh like an isolated
low lower surrogate
then
that's not a valid code point and
therefore it's not valid utf-16
right yes
right now
now basically
the
right so
right we can represent
uh the code point for a
you know surrogate
for a single surrogate
you know just fine in fact in utf-8 you
could theoretically encode these code
points because these are just numbers
you know
in the 50 000 which are very easy to
encode using utf-8
so the problem is what what happens if
you create as a string
that contains
right so a valid string for us
would never have one of these code
points because either
you would have
you know an action i guess
right
yeah if you're in character mode as
opposed to blob mode
and you slice off one of these and you
have a naked one of these
no no no it's it's it's it's not a
character versus blob right it's it's
you know
if you had something that's actually a
character
actually a valid code point
then it would not be in this range it
would either be above or below
right and
irrespective of whatever our internal
encoding is which is a variant of utf-8
if you know if we want to talk about
that i don't know what i guess the front
end uses utf-16
um
but the kernel uses a variant of utf-8
um
and
and so right if you do basically what
happens if you do from you know two
character code of 56 000 right that's
not a valid character you can't have a
string that contains that character and
still be a valid unicode string
yep
and so
then the question is
but you know in the past we allowed this
and so now the question is well how does
it print
well that's what i'm showing you right
so that pink box
is one of those
one of those characters so i'm sorry so
if i say from character code
of 56 000 yep
and pink and i'm pink and i'm
buzzing like this yes well and and so
the underlying issue is
well but then the question is
well well what before we put in the not
insignificant
effort to do better than that we need to
decide what the end goal is and if you
look right if you do now percent slash
input form
you'll get
nothing
and i you know i could stick in the
debugger and try to figure out where
that output went but
the short of it is you know we're
sending around junk and and so we're
getting random behavior
well and and and actually
in fact math link is an active player
here
uh because math link uh
you know if you say you want to receive
something as utf-16
it's going to confirm
that
what you have is actually representable
in utf-16 and it's very
picky about making sure you follow the
standard
and if you don't instead of giving you
something that might not be uts-16 it
will give you an error
oh gosh
well look
my immediate response would be just as
we
if you give me something which for which
i do not have a font character it will
show up as some weird you know
non-printable thing
i would have expected the same to be
true here
just as since you're showing me that the
us flag when broken apart is a you and
an s
i would expect here that the naked you
know broken apart
character combiner character from the
16-bit pieces
would just be
a a disembodied
you know
naked surrogate as you're calling it
um
and that that we just would display as
some kind of you know i'm not available
character
why wouldn't that be the case
other than the fact that it's hard to
track down all the places in the code
where the assumption is made that the
thing is valid
i uh well i i
i i mean i think that is in principle do
doable john may have opinions on that uh
i'm i'm
well the problem is how do you
how do you represent
uh an invalid code point using only code
points
so you could for example uh you know
dedicate a range of the private use area
and say these things map to uh to the
two invalid code points but then
you know that's really something that's
so pointless i mean that's that's
but but then if someone tries to
represent those things
right yeah and and then the other issue
is i mean what happens if you try to
copy and paste one of these outputs i
mean if you're just missing
the glyph right then you copy it and
paste it into an external program it
might uh
you know it may or may not display but
you know in principle if it's a you know
a unicode aware program that bytecode
you know that sequence of bytes will
just sit there
but here this is something actually
invalid so you know i don't okay i don't
know what happens
creates it creates a lot of round
tripping issues yeah okay so hold on so
what are some examples of other things
that are just meaningless like numbers
with no precision are a little bit like
this but not quite because they actually
do contain information they just are not
displayable they're not
uh what else do we have that is just
meaningless by
structure so to speak
a syntax error is meaningless by
structure
i mean could we treat this thing
what kind of a thing is this
it does have a very distinct
feeling of a space-time singularity
um
god okay all right so and to be clear i
mean it's i think it's pretty
straightforward to
have you know sensible
error handling around this but
but you know
error handling
let's just make it a freaking error i
mean
that to me is the thing is
so so from character code would return
an error rather than a string
or or none or something
is what you're saying
sorry so then again i got distracted
what the from character code the 56 000
rather than returning a string with junk
in it would just fail is what you're
suggesting i think it would just fail
okay
now where else can you get to that
right so
um
right so you can type these in right you
could do
you know whatever
right so the front end would need to
know to
not
just don't parse it right to
you know just leave it what other what
other hatches do we have to batten down
i i feel like i could construct one of
these things using j-link i might be
misremembering and it might actually be
that i can try to do that and then i
crash things
um but i would i would wonder about
okay but what about things
taking okay that's one thing
um
you know if you generate a string
in the evaluator that contains just this
thing
i claim it should return not a string
so basically basically the string
constructor needs to fail if you create
a quote-unquote character in this range
a code point i mean what we could do it
might be
more civilized
to if you do manage to create a string
with just this character in it
i mean why not just return another
string with an error character in it why
not pick an error character and have all
of these okay this is an alternative
proposal okay
everything like this becomes an error
string so therefore fifty six thousand
and fifty six thousand and one both
mapped to the same thing
and they're both error strings
there's another possibility i'm i'm
quite happy with that
any solution which doesn't require
round-tripping i think is going to be
very achievable
okay i mean look what we could do and
that's that's wonderful okay so one
thing we could do here generate a
message when you say from character code
of 56 000 and then generate an error
character
okay yeah i think i think that's
probably the most straightforward
solution so he's family
famously says before looking at the
horrifying string code that we have but
um but but i think this would
you know so i mean if you do something
like character range that overlaps you
know the invalid areas then you'll get a
bunch of individual error strings and i
think that that seems like it's okay
it's fine i mean this is a deeply corner
case this is a corner of a corner of a
corner right i mean it has been reported
externally mostly by people who don't
actually know the unicode standard and
so they try to do right they do a table
over all 16 bit values and then they're
like why do i see these horrible pink
boxes
now if we give a sensible message and
substitute an error character then
they'll know what's happening right so
fine we have to pick the error character
we have to design it or pick it from a
unicode thing
and um
that
okay and i can make one of these things
using j-link just for the record
why this is our strings okay let's just
look at this one and we should probably
wrap up um
what on earth is this one import string
cannot import as json
from strings containing
right so right so we have this ancient
design decision from i know version five
or something right that import string
basically treats a string as a sequence
of bytes
as a as a compact form of a list of
bytes
and so if and because
not have that why do we have that i mean
why can't we have an option that
switches that off
um
[Music]
it just seems wrong to me
it's well be
[Music]
uh well i mean it would be an option
that only affects import string which
would be i think unprecedented right
because it can't affect import or and it
can't affect import byte array which are
literally dealing with bytes right but
the point here with import string is
that unicode became ubiquitous during
the time from when we originally
designed this to now
previously import string had to have
worry about character encodings
no no no no no that's not at all true if
you do if right if you do
right read string
of of uh of a json file
right you will get bytes corresponding
to the utf-8 and then you'd want import
string to interpret that not as
you know characters but as
uh you know a bunch of utf-8 bytes
because json by definition is a sequence
of utf-8 bytes
that is what the standard for json
specifies
i'm sorry if you brought them in from a
file or something it's a series of bytes
like that
is that what you i'm sorry yes
okay but if but it's if it already was
turned in if the file already was turned
into a string no no if you do read
string on that file it's right it's a
bunch of bytes
okay
right
and right right we have this equivalence
for
just about everything where right import
string of string
right import a file and import string of
read string of that file are the same
thing and
you know certainly as long as there are
only
byte values in there we have to preserve
that
i don't understand why i mean maybe i'm
i'm probably frying out from
too much of this but but
in this case why are we this obnoxious
why don't we just say okay it's a
unicode thing that was a let's just
interpret it as unicode we know it's
unicode so why don't we just go ahead
and interpret it
because it's not valid json right that's
a wolfram language string that looks
like json but isn't json
oh right you should have taken your
wolfram language string and called
export string with json which would have
encoded it properly
or or you know okay so what you're
saying is
if we've got pseudo json right using
unicode what should we do
right and and in particular
and in particular there's i mean that is
sort of
i think the most
recent iteration of this thing but the
the sort of has come up
uh you know a number of times that if
you want to convert a string between
you know the bytes between two different
uh
encodings right you need to do this as
sort of obnoxious you need to do
character code in one and then from
character code in the other
or you know and and if you if you really
just want the bytes you can do string to
bite array and then import that byte
array
and so maybe what we need is just an
encode string function that
automates this conversion for you i
think that would be sensible that goes
from one character encoding to another
which otherwise you have to do by going
from two why not yep
that seems sensible to me i think that
in this particular using that as a
suggestion in this case misleading users
though
which suggestion why
because they already have something that
isn't valid json and we're just trying
to kind of fudge it and make it look
like it's json well
but no if the users re-encode their
string as utf-8 so if they just come out
yeah then they're in good shape
right we've exactly solved the problem
that's that's a fine solution there the
question is i look around but i do think
it's misleading
but there's nothing misleading about it
which i'm going to claim isn't quite
right
we'd still generate exactly these error
messages
exactly the same this would be identical
it would merely be that there's a piece
of documentation that you can find that
says you can use encode string to to
re-encode this
that make sense sean
yeah i understand it
is that do you have an objection to that
i i mean i think i already gave it but
if we want to give users a way to kind
of translate between
because they already ended up in this
scenario i don't understand what your
objection is
i don't know why you end up with a
string that looks like json that has
unicode characters in it to me that
means that somewhere along the line none
of you were given something that was
already encoded
you start well you've started with this
thing because you were create right you
were creating this string in wolfram
language
and now can i make a suggestion then you
should have exported that string to json
right
no no
we don't know where that string came
from you constructed that string
incorrectly by some piece of you were
trying to be too clever and you were
taking you know names in greek and you
were putting them in and you didn't
transliterate them okay and you didn't
encode it correctly and you got it wrong
but you were constructing that immortal
language for example
okay
now
i would argue that we could imagine
another import type called unicode json
or json unicode or something which would
allow this
which would say to hell with the unicode
standard i don't care about utf-8 i'm
just going to take these as unicode
characters and i'm going to deal with
them
in that scenario then fine and code
string i think is the right solution
definitely not a unicode json
oh yeah but i mean it's not the unicode
standard right it's it's the json
standard right i know i know i know i
know but i'm saying the json standard
says use utf-8
okay
what we're dealing with here
i don't know what we call it but but but
basically it's you managed to get this
thing into a string where we don't need
utf-8 because we have a way of encoding
our strings so that we know it's an
alpha we don't need to see it as its
utf-8 bytes
right but but then suppose it's a it's a
plus minus is that a plus minus because
you've already converted it to utf-8
and or is it a plus minus because you
actually want the plus minus
why are you bringing up the plus minus
example because if you do
uh that's the utf-8 weird case right
because because if you because the utf
one of the two bytes in the utf-8
representation of alpha is plus minus
okay
i think we have to continue this another
time i'm i'm i i didn't mean to get us
off track honestly i think the encode
string solution is perfectly fine
all right i mean thinking code string is
a useful function anyway
um i agree and i think you know whether
these messages are quite right for the
import string thing
yeah we could definitely do better on on
the error messages yeah i don't have
three messages and and they're i mean if
you look at the tags they're they're
json specific so we could certainly add
a dedicated message page for
for but also don't generate three
i messages not write this code i just
discovered that there are three messages
last night so i i don't disagree with
you i'm i'm just don't want to be held
responsible for it fair enough
okay
all right
good stuff well done everybody i think
that's probably everything we can
fit in for today let me know
thank you all right sounds good thanks
to folks on